RICHARD FULCHER: So
good morning.
Welcome to a session
entirely devoted to
navigation in Android.
My name's Rich Fulcher.
I'm one of the interaction
designers on the Android user
experience team.
ADAM POWELL: And I'm
Adam Powell.
I'm a framework engineer
in Mountain View.
RICHARD FULCHER: And we both
care passionately about
navigation.
In fact, when I first applied to
work at Google three years
ago, resolving questions with
Back was part of my first
interview to become an
interaction designer here.
So we're going to take
you through a
lot of content today.
So to get started, to really
understand tasks in Android,
first, you have to have
a good understanding
of how tasks behave.
And then Adam will help set
the stage for that.
ADAM POWELL: So a lot of early
Android apps talked about
being task managers.
But generally, they were
actually talking about
managing processes.
In Android, a process can be
a container for multiple
components.
And a task can contain
activities hosted by many
different processes.
They really aren't
the same thing.
RICHARD FULCHER: So let's
just do a couple
of examples of this.
This is a really simple task
that we'll build out.
We're going to open Gmail.
And we're going to dive in
and view a conversation.
And the way I'm going to show
a bunch of examples during
this talk is with this format.
The left-hand side of the screen
will show the state of
the task stack as activities
are added to it.
And the right-hand side will
show the screen progression
that the user experiences
as they navigate.
So starting here, we start
at the Home screen.
We have the Launcher activity
at the base of the
task stack for us.
Clicking on the Gmail icon
from Home opens up the
activity for the Gmail
Conversation List.
I'm just going to use wire
frames throughout this talk,
just to keep the focus on
the navigation itself.
So that has added the
Conversation List activity
onto the task stack.
If I navigate deeper, I go
down into a particular
conversation to view the
messages inside of that.
Then the Conversation View
was added as well.
And that's just building
up a very simple task.
Another slightly more
complicated example involves
activities that are coming from
multiple applications.
Adam mentioned that we can do
this within a single task.
That's one of the strengths
of Android.
So I'm going to start
at Home again.
I'm going to build into--
enter into Talk, where I see the
Friend List, the list of
everybody I can have a
conversation with.
I'll pick a particular friend
from that list.
Go into the Chat View.
That activity gets added on.
Let's say that friend had sent
me a link to a YouTube video.
I can continue into a different
application.
In this case, I can
go to YouTube.
And that activity is added to
the task stack as well--
the same system.
We're just adding and
adding and adding on
top to the task stack.
And I can go further.
If I wanted to watch this video
and then share it with a
friend, I could hit
the Share button.
And that'll take me to Gmail's
Compose Screen, yet another
activity that we just drop
onto the task stack.
So now we finish this example.
We've got Launcher at the
root of the stack.
We've got activities from three
different applications,
all part of this one
continuous task.
And this is the way that tasks
have always worked inside of
Android, all the way back
to Android 1.0.
And one particular control,
the Back button, has been
along for the whole ride.
Although over time, it's changed
its appearance a
little bit.
It's now trimmer than
it used to be.
So Back works by unwinding
that task stack
that we build up.
It actually unwinds the
global history stack.
We'll get into that in a
little bit more detail.
It finishes off the
current activity.
So when I hit Back, the activity
has the opportunity
to do things, save out
any local state
that it wants to preserve.
And then clears itself away
off the task stack.
And the ActivityManager brings
forward the next lower down
activity and presents
that to the user.
Now, of course, there are
a couple of exceptions.
Most of these just relate to
when Back handles a local bit
of state within the activity.
So things like if the virtual
keyboard is displayed, Back
will recede that.
If there are dialogues or
spinners that have popped
open, Back will dismiss those.
If you have a selection mode,
Back will get rid of that.
And then a subsequent press of
Back in all of those cases
will actually act as
the navigation.
There are also a few instances
where Back is completely taken
over by the application.
The browser is the most obvious
and notable example of
that, where Back becomes back
through your browsing history,
kind of historical browsing
context within browser.
So going back to the two
examples we covered at the
start, what does Back do?
Well, it's actually really
simple in both cases.
Back from Gmail just pops that
activity off the stack.
And the Conversation List
comes to the front.
Hitting Back again finishes
that activity,
returns me to Home.
Same is true for the slightly
more complex case.
Again, we built up these
different activities from
different apps.
But Back just walks through
them just as comfortably.
Back, Back, Back,
Back to Home.
And once we're at Home,
there's no place
further back to go.
So Back loses meaning once
it lands in that context.
You've got a safe root
point to do all of
your exploration from.
So now Adam's going to talk a
little bit about how multiple
tasks work.
ADAM POWELL: Right.
We've been focused on single
tasks so far, but how do
multiple tasks behave?
So you might have noticed that
the Recents list here is a
whole lot like something else
that you might be used to
using day to day.
So it's very similar to
your browser tab list.
But so how do tasks really
work in the context of
Android with this?
What are all those intent flags
that you see in the
developer documentation?
There's a lot about how tasks
work internally that isn't
immediately obvious.
But it really helps make things
feel right to the user
when they're all put together.
And it's useful for you as a
developer to know how a bunch
of this stuff is going on under
the hood, even if your
users don't have to.
So ActivityManager, which is the
component that ties all of
this navigation together, sees
the world as one big global
activity stack sorted by task.
So this might explain some of
the behavior that you've seen
here and there that might have
made you scratch your head.
So if I hit Back a few times,
I'll pop from the top of the
stack until I hit Home.
Home then prevents me from
popping further.
The rest of the stack still
exists, though.
This is part of my
global navigation
history across the system.
So we said before that your list
of tasks in Android is
very similar to your
tabs in a browser.
So how do you open a new tab?
How do you create a new task?
So in an example here, from
Home, we open Talk.
A new task is created.
And further navigation
within Talk just adds
to that same task.
So how many of you use tabbed
browsing out there?
Show of hands?
OK, pretty much everybody.
So keep your hand up if you end
up with way too many tabs
open at the end of the day.
Oh, look at that.
Just as many people.
So we really didn't want to have
the same problem happen
in Android.
Because manually curating your
browser tabs really stinks.
You have to do this manual
garbage collection pass every
now and then, just to make sure
that things stay cleaned
up and that you can still
understand what the heck
you're doing on your desktop.
So we have this idea called
Task Affinity in Android.
Task Affinity lets us keep a
single context associated with
a task instead of multiple
tasks that
are very, very similar.
And this avoids having multiple
tabs open for doing
the same thing.
So how does this work?
When we launch an activity into
a new task here and a
task with the same affinity
already exists, then the
existing task gets brought
to the front.
Now, if the intent that we just
launched matches the root
intent of that existing task,
the one that's at the very
bottom of the task stack,
then we're done.
We have nothing else to do.
So what it means for an intent
to match is a little
unintuitive if you're not
familiar with this particular
little detail here, is that
intent extras don't count.
They're always app specific.
And the system really doesn't
even pretend to know how to
unparcel them and compare them
for any sort of equivalence.
So that means that intents can
match even if they have very
different extras.
But all of this put together
means that this is why
Launcher is able to act as a
task switcher on its own.
Shortcuts always launch
a new task.
And it's always the root
activity of that task if it
was already existing.
So before Honeycomb, this is how
a lot of users got around
the system.
You would just hit Home.
And then you would reopen
the app that you wanted.
But it would reopen to exactly
the same state that it was in
the previous time that
you were using it.
RICHARD FULCHER: So now
we've got a handle
on how tasks work.
We've talked a little bit
about affinity, how Back
behaves, but navigation
has evolved
during Android's history.
And in particular, we'll talk
about Up and Recents, and how
they've been added.
So let's bring the
timeline back up.
By the start of 2010, we knew
we kind of had a problem.
Or more exactly, we knew that
our users were having several
problems when it came to
navigation within Android.
We had system-level controls
for navigation.
We had Back, which we've
talked about.
And we had Home.
Home was kind of a task
switcher, but it was a little
bit awkward for that.
I'd have to hit the Home key.
I'd come back to the
Home screen.
Maybe the task I'm trying to
switch to isn't on that Home
screen, so I might have
to locate it.
Or maybe it is on any of the
Home screens, and I have to
bring up the All Apps
drawer to find it.
We had a more elegant way of
doing that, which was our
Recents control, which you'd
invoke by kind of long
pressing on Home.
And it would bring
up not a lot of
details about the tasks.
You'd get five application
icons and five labels.
But we knew from listening to
the users that people just
didn't know this function
existed.
It was really a very hidden,
power-user feature.
And users were craving something
that was a lot more
obvious than that.
What about for the
application-level navigation controls?
These are switching
between tasks--
or moving within the task.
What about inside an app?
We didn't have any story
really there.
Now, that didn't stop charming,
clever developers
such as yourselves from
coming up with ways
to work around this.
One popular one was to take
the Menu button and to add
additional actions into that
that would target specific
activities within your
application.
So it might be that you added
an action to go to the
Home of your app.
Or to go to a common screen
like an Account list or an
inbox, those types of things.
Another approach that a lot of
apps took was to take the Back
button and try to turn it into
something like a structural
navigation element by overriding
its behavior.
A lot of apps did this.
I've worked on apps
that did this--
[COUGH]
Gmail.
But it made the Back button very
inconsistent for users.
They couldn't really predict
what was going to happen when
in certain contexts we'd
get overridden and
do something different.
So we wanted to address those.
I think a problem that happened
with a lot of early
Android applications is that it
was easy to build them in a
way that it was just kind of
like a bag of activities that
you would throw your
activities into.
And you could shake it up.
And the user could move to
different activities through
whatever affordances you
wanted to give them.
And there might be
a top doorway in.
But once you started diving in
a little bit, you could get
these paths that were a little
bit formless, a little bit
unpredictable, and could even
have circuits in the path
where I start from one
screen and follow a
forward-navigating path
that takes me back
to that same screen.
In which case Back gets
quite interesting.
We definitely heard from
coworkers, from users, a lot
of frustration.
And when people are frustrated,
they come talk to
their designers.
So we didn't want to be
associated with this.
We wanted to take this problem
head on and really try to do
something about it.
So we did.
We started at I/O
two years ago.
Myself and a few other members
of the user experience team
were on a stage about this
size, talking about five
interface patterns that we
thought were helpful for app
developers.
And one of the ones we
introduced in that session,
talked about, was
the Action Bar.
So the Action Bar was trying
to solve two problems.
The first was to make the most
common actions more visible.
And you've heard about that in
the sessions earlier today, so
I won't go there.
But the other thing it tried
to do is give a sense of
structure and place
to the app.
The Action Bar was intended
to replace the
old Title Bar element.
Internally, we called it the
Interactive Title Bar for
quite a while.
So the area at the left would
give you the app icon and the
name of the activity that you
were currently viewing.
But it would also be a touch
target for jumping back up to
the top of the application.
In the same way that a user
might expect to touch at the
logo at the upper left corner
of a website, it's going to
come back to the home
of that site.
So we're trying to play
off those conventions.
Now that said, what we gave you
at I/O two years ago was
far from perfect.
It was an interface pattern.
It wasn't supported
by the framework.
It wasn't a code pattern yet.
We were just kind of offering,
this would be a good thing for
you to go and do.
And it also only supported one
target, which was navigating
directly to the top of
the application.
And for some apps that's fine,
and that's suitable.
For apps with deeper hierarchy,
you want to have a
little bit more subtlety
than that.
At the time, we were
demonstrating the Facebook app
and the Twitter app during
that session.
And those have a much richer
set of activities.
They have entire subsections
to those apps.
And a little bit more navigation
control would have
been appropriate.
So in 2010, we did
Gingerbread.
It didn't really change
the story there.
But in 2011 and 2012,
we really started
tackling this problem.
We wanted to take the direction
we'd laid out with
that alpha version of the
Action Bar and really
reinforce the story
that was there.
And even as we were chatting at
I/O two years ago, we were
already hard at work
on our tablet UI.
So we started rolling that
thought right into Honeycomb,
what would become the
full Action Bar.
And then in ICS, we brought
it to phone with even more
capabilities.
And navigation was a critical
part of that.
So a lot of what we tried to do
in those two releases was
motivated by what we saw
from user research.
We did very frequent testing
for Honeycomb.
Literally, we would have two or
three sessions a week with
four or five different
participants in a given
session for four months when
we were testing Honeycomb.
And during all of those tests,
we were testing navigation to
some extent.
We were testing a lot of
different applications.
But that kind of glue that
let the user get to the
applications, switch between
them, was always something
that we were looking at.
When I think about evaluating
what research can do for you,
I think the wrong question that
people ask too often is
if they do an experiment.
And then they say, well, did
the product test well?
I think a more valuable question
to ask is, did we
glean some new insights
to the problems that
we're trying to solve?
And when it comes to navigation
and the work we did
in Honeycomb, we
learned a lot.
Our four big takeaways were this
notion of the navigation
being in the upper left corner
of the screen calling back to
their experience with the web
and with other devices was
really powerful for users
and felt very natural.
Users wanted to make a clear
distinction between navigation
that kept you inside an
application and navigation
controls that were
outside of it.
So users definitely had a
distinction between things
that we would render in the
applications content area and
things that would be rendered
in the System bar.
Or more typically at the time,
that would be physical
hardware controls that
were on the device.
It was sometimes a mapping
problem moving between those
two sets for users.
And users also want to have a
safe form of the navigation.
They wanted to know that the
affordances or the controls
that they would use would be
able to keep them within the
app that they were currently
viewing.
Users were incredibly frustrated
when they would
press a Back button and
unexpectedly be jettisoned
from an app.
That's back to our bag of
activities from before.
And then finally--
quick, obvious--
task switching was super
important to them.
So we wanted to address that.
So we added two controls in
Honeycomb and ICS to cover
those issues.
Up was looking at those
first three issues.
The upper left corner, the
inside-outside problem, and
the predictability of
remaining within the
application, that safety
guarantee.
And Recents was our way of
taking that question of task
switching and making it dead
obvious for the user.
So I'll goes into detail on
both of these, first Up.
Up is structural navigation.
We've hit that point a couple
of times today,
but I'll hit it again.
It's going to keep
you in the app.
When you're at the top of the
app, you don't even see it
because it's all about
navigating in the app.
You're at the top.
There's no further to go.
It's completely independent
of the task state.
So all those examples that I
showed before of how the task
stack builds, your behavior of
Up isn't affected by what's on
that task stack.
It's based entirely upon the
relationships between the
different activities that you've
constructed in your
app, the right parent/child
relationships that exist there.
It can alter the task stack as
a side effect, but it's not
dependent upon it.
And then as a result,
Up is not Back.
They sometimes will have the
same effect for the user.
But they behave differently.
And there are a couple of
critical cases where they're
actually quite different.
So let's dive into those.
So the first is when you're
doing a browsing session.
And you're going to
Related Views.
So an example here that we'll
use is, I've gone into the
Play store.
I'm looking at a
list of books.
Maybe it's the featured books.
And I pick a book that I want
to view more details about.
And I go and I see that
Book Details screen.
Now, part of a lot of store
experiences is that part of
the item's display will
give you a list of
related content items--
you know, users also liked--
that might show other books.
And when you browse to that and
you click on that, we give
you another Book Details
activity.
And now, we've got two Book
Details activity.
The same type of activity, but
two different instances of it
get built onto the task stack.
And now obviously, this
can extend from there.
So the question becomes,
Back will do one thing.
Back will unwind you through
that browsing history.
I was looking at this book.
I went and looked at
a related book.
Now I'd like to come back
to that first book.
Up is structural navigation.
Up gives you the ability to
bypass that intermediate state
and return up to that
original list.
Now, that may not seem
like that big a deal
for this short example.
But imagine browser sessions
that could get quite lengthy.
I might go from book
to book to book to
book to book to book.
And then in the old school, I
could go Back to Back to Back
to Back to Back, to
Back to Back.
Up lets you skip all
that and just jump
right up to the list.
The second instance where Back
and Up differ critically is
when you have a task that's
being built up from multiple
applications.
And so I'll go through
one here.
I'll start at Home.
I'll go into YouTube.
I'm browsing a list
of YouTube videos.
I'll pick one out, and
I'll watch it.
And then I'll elect to
share it over Gmail.
So the Gmail Compose activity
comes to the
front of the task stack.
So from here, Back is going
to do the natural thing.
If I decide I don't really want
to share that cat video
with my friend, Back gets me out
of that context, takes me
back to the lovely cat video.
But if instead I wanted to
remain within Gmail--
maybe the fact of firing up that
Compose reminded me of
something else I
needed to do--
the Up lets me stay inside.
And, in fact, it'll take me to
a higher level activity that
wasn't in the task stack
at any point.
This is going to graduate me
up to the Conversation List
and the inbox that's
associated with it.
And a couple of critical
things happen here.
We add that activity.
We finish the Compose
activity.
That one's gone.
And we split the task.
So we have one task, our old
YouTube task, now sans that
useless Gmail Compose
activity.
And we have a new task, the
Gmail task focused on the
Conversation List.
And we've also carried
along Home's Launcher
activity for the ride.
So that if I'm at the
Conversation List and now I
hit Back, I'll actually
wind up back at Home.
Recents is actually pretty
straightforward.
It behaves the same as it did
for that hidden function way
back in [? Android .1 ?].
But what we've significantly
changed in Honeycomb was to
just give the user a much
cleaner interaction with it.
We introduced a dedicated button
in the system or in the
navigation area.
It brings the entire
task stack forward.
And we just added a lot of
detail that helps the user
make that decision.
Instead of just getting the name
and the app icon, we're
now giving the user those plus
a screen shot of the topmost
activity in that task stack.
Which is helpful for
both identifying--
where's that task I'm trying
to get back to?
Oh, it's this map.
Yeah, it's that map.
As well as orienting the
user for the switch.
The user's already remembering
the context that they're going
to be going into even before
that animation completes.
So it's a much less jarring
transition for the user, which
made it much better.
Finally, we're delivering on
that great multitasking story
that we always knew Android
was capable of supporting.
ADAM POWELL: So coming back to
our diagram from before, when
I choose Task B from Recents
here, what actually happens?
So when you bring Task B to the
top using the Recents UI,
Recents is starting the
root activity of Task
B with these flags.
Remember, when we start the root
activity of a task, it
brings it forward.
So we've already covered what
New Task does but what about
this Task on Home thing?
So this was a new flag that
we added in Honeycomb.
And this is the flag that allows
us to bring Launcher
along for the ride, like
Rich mentioned.
To keep this more consistent
state that is more predictable
for users when they
switch around.
So after that switch, Task
B is now on top with Home
immediately beneath it.
And if I back through Gmail,
I'll end up on Home no matter
how I got into Gmail,
just as I expect.
RICHARD FULCHER: So one last
visit to the timeline.
So we talked about Honeycomb.
We talked about ICS.
And today, we are proud
to announce--
nothing else new.
We haven't changed it.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD FULCHER:
You're welcome.
ADAM POWELL: So now you know a
little bit more of the history
of how we got where
we are here.
And it's important to remember
that it's really easy to find
these local maxima for your
app's experiences and sort of
implement special functionality
to make that happen.
But following system conventions
makes your app
more intuitive to people that
already know how other apps
behave in the system, when
those apps follow those
conventions too.
But as you've already seen, the
Android framework has a
lot of intricate options and
opportunities to do things
differently.
So how do we actually implement
all these guidelines
that we're talking about here?
Well, Back is really easy.
We just leave it alone.
Let it go ahead and unwind
fragment transactions or
finish activities just as
it does by default.
And let it move to the previous
activity in the task,
so on and so forth.
But what about this Up thing?
So we talked before about
how Up can switch tasks.
When you deliberately task
switch, here's how you bring
Launcher along for the ride
the way that Recents does.
And we talked about
this a little bit.
But this really helps reinforce
this hub and spoke
model of tasks for the users
with Launcher as this hub.
Each one of the tasks
kind of splits
out, forming the spokes.
When a task is fully replaced,
then traversing back through a
synthetic stack and returning
to the previous task instead
feels really, really weird.
So landing at Home reinforces
structure.
So when we implement Up, we need
to fully replace the task
that's there.
Again, because of this new tabs
problem that we talked
about before.
By replacing the task, we're
effectively sort of faking
history, though.
And some of you may be
wondering, why would you
really want to do that?
Why not just have
Back be Back?
Why are you lying
to the users?
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah, there are
actually a few different
cases where the activity that's
the logical parent may
or may not be something that's
already on that task stack.
So we'll see this in more detail
when we talk about
widgets and notifications
in just a little bit.
And they actually behave
very similarly
to Up in that regard.
ADAM POWELL: So that means
that another ability that
we'll need is being able to
replace an existing task.
So for example, imagine that the
user's at Home with tasks
they've already built up for
Gmail, Talk, and YouTube.
That's A, B, and C as listed
on the slide here.
So from Home, the user
navigates into
Gmail from its widget.
So this needs to be sort of
a deep link in there.
Then it's the same story for Up
when you're composing from
a different task, like in
our previous example.
So using that widget will
make the old task
state of Gmail invalid.
So we use this Clear Task flag,
since we don't want
leftover state or duplicate
Gmail tasks anywhere in the
global activities stack.
So as much as systems
programmers really enjoy
packing arrays full of values
and getting exact flag
combinations right through all
of that, we really wanted to
provide a little bit of a nicer
interface on top of that
to help get the details right.
So in both the Jellybean
framework and in the support
library, TaskStackBuilder
is that nicer interface.
So it can determine the full
synthetic task stack that
you'll need based on the
structural hierarchy from the
declared parent activities in
your manifest, as well as
generate some pending intents
for notifications and launcher
widgets when you need those.
We've got some code examples in
the SDK that you can take a
look at for more details.
So how do we pull all these
little pieces together to
implement Up?
Well, the good news is that in
Jellybean, you don't have to.
It's all completely
done for you.
Just give us the metadata in
your manifest about the parent
activities.
And we'll take care of
everything else.
So sometimes you need to specify
some other intent
extras to those activities
along the way.
For example, if one of your
parent activities is a
category view and you need to
know what category you're
viewing, you may express
that as some sort
of an intent extra.
So in that case, you can
override an activity method
and edit the intents in the
TaskStackBuilder that's being
used under the hoods whenever
it's needed.
So we'll also be bringing this
to the AppCompat component of
the support library that we
talked about yesterday in the
multi-versioning Android
UI session, if
any of you were there.
RICHARD FULCHER: So the last
major topic we need to cover
as far as navigation goes is
widgets and notifications.
And these are both examples of
a pattern we internally call
deep links.
These are things that let you
bypass certain intro screens
in an app and target an activity
that's deeper within
its hierarchy.
Widgets are pretty
straightforward in the sense
that we know that those are
always going to be new tasks.
You're always firing
them from Home.
They're effectively acting
as a Launcher activity.
They can apply task affinity as
Adam talked about before.
But they're not that complex.
Notifications are a little
trickier, so
we'll cover those last.
So here's just a quick example
showing widgets.
So back to the old format, we've
got the task stack and
the screens building up.
So from Home, I have a Gmail
widget on my Home screen.
And I see a conversation
within my inbox,
and I touch on that.
That lets you bypass the
Conversation List screen, and
you navigate directly to
the Conversation View.
But actually representing
that screen in the
task stack is valuable.
Keeping that Conversation List
around matters a lot.
It doesn't matter so much
right now, like
right at this instant.
But where it matters a lot to
the user is when they've been
inside Gmail for awhile.
They come in.
They read that message.
They read several other
conversations past that.
And they've been in the app
for a little while,
and they hit Back.
They're not aware that instant
that, oh, the doorway I used
to enter was the widget.
So of course, it's going
to kick me out to Home.
It's a surprising change if
we were to just do that.
So we don't.
When the widget calls into the
Conversation View, you can add
the Conversation List activity
to the task stack.
That way when the user hits Up
or Back, they're being kept
within the application.
If they really wanted to go
Home, well, they could have
hit Home to begin with.
Or they could just
hit Back again.
Notifications--
so a common flow for
notifications
is I'm in one app.
So I start Home.
I launch again into Gmail.
I'm reading a conversation.
And in comes a notification.
I pull down the shade.
No activity.
No task stack change there.
That's just purely local.
And I've got a new notification
from Talk.
A new message has come in,
and I want to read that.
So I tap that notification.
And now we have the Talk
activity to deal with.
And we're going to go straight
to the Chat View.
Again, we're bypassing that
Friends chat or the Friends
List that we'd seen in
the earlier examples.
The question here is, what
should the relationship
between that new activity
and the prior task be?
Is this going to
be a new task?
Is this just something
that we put on top of
the previous task?
ADAM POWELL: So knowing what you
now know about how all of
this fits together and what we
found our users' expectations
were, not just right immediately
but several hours
later, this really
doesn't work.
We can't just hop back
to the previous task.
This is something that became
muscle memory for a lot of
users over time in previous
versions of Android.
You answer a notification.
You do whatever you
need to do there.
And then you hit Back.
And then you continue doing
what you're doing.
So this actually caused
us a lot of problems.
It was trivially easy to create
this super confusing
state that users wouldn't
discover
until much, much later.
So something really
needed to change.
So the problem that it created
was that the task stack was no
longer predictable.
If you last opened Gmail through
a notification, hours
or days later your Gmail task
state would be very different
than if you had opened it
through the front door.
So as you go switching back and
forth between tasks just
as you use your device,
then this gets
really massively confusing.
And users just started
attributing this to Android
being dumb or confusing,
one thing or another.
So the idea of Back staying
within the current task is
something that we weren't
willing to give up.
There's a ton of psychology
behind maintaining that
expectation in each task.
Context switches are very,
very powerful.
People remember a lot
about an old context
when they switch back.
And then they forget about
the context that
they switched from.
So have you ever walk through
a doorway into another room
and suddenly forgotten
what you were doing?
You're not alone in this.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah, there
was actually a pretty
well-known psych study that
covered this exact topic that
got some play in the popular
press, so you may
have heard about it.
And it looked at what happens
when participants were asked
to engage in memory tests
while they were walking
through doorways.
And they did it in both physical
and in virtual
environments.
Spoiler alert, people forgot
stuff when they walked through
the doorway.
So we didn't want our users to
suffer the same fate when they
did the task switch.
I have to just call
out in this quote.
I love this little
bit that talks
about episodes of activity.
I read this quote--
I swear I didn't doctor it.
And that just screams task stack
to me when I look at it.
ADAM POWELL: OK, so
we have all of
these crazy flags available.
Can we cheat a little bit?
Can we really keep that flow of
just hitting Back and going
right back to where
we wanted to be?
So here's one possible trick.
We could start a new task
but don't set the
Task on Home flag.
Well, this trick will make
the Back button work
for this use case.
But the rest of the existing
task still ends up being there
to mash back through.
And that's really
not very great.
And if we add the Clear Task
flag, then it really leaves us
with a bogus state.
Back becomes unpredictable
either way.
If you clear the task, then
returning to that task later
from Recents means you Back
right back into Home again.
If you don't, then you have to
Back through the rest of the
task before you get back
to the previous task.
And you still lost
the quick Back.
So that's not going to work.
So, OK, what if we really,
really cheat?
You can try a really
dirty trick here.
But this will leave this
orphaned activity hanging
around that you won't actually
be able to get back to in any
sort of a discoverable way.
If you answered a notification
and then wrote half of a
message in Talk, then you're
basically hosed if you leave
and want to come back.
And then you get into this
matter of, OK, well, we could
go ahead and make everyone try
and save drafts for everything
that you're doing one
thing or another.
But we really didn't think it
was a good idea to expect
developers or even want them
to take on this much
duplication in special casing.
So notifications are supposed
to be this first-class thing
in Android.
But just as a note, this trick
actually is useful in some
other cases.
So if you have a deliberately
orphaned summary dialogue or a
screen that shows more than a
notification can on its own
but it's really just an
extension of that notification
before you jump into the
content, then this can be
really useful.
Calendar reminders are one place
where we do this in the
base Android system.
When you get a pop up that shows
multiple reminders that
have been collapsed.
So the solution that we finally
settled on was that we
treat notifications just like
we treat widgets in Up.
So that means that navigating
into an app from a
notification replaces the target
task entirely with that
same sort of deep link synthetic
task stack that we
use for Up and for widgets.
So conceptually that means
notifications have become a
shortcut for going Home,
clearing out the current task
state by swiping away in
Recents, opening the app, and
then just following the shortest
path down the UI to
get to the content that you
actually cared about.
But you're doing it
all in one step.
So TaskStackBuilder gives
you an easy way
to accomplish this.
So the implications of this are
that, yeah, we really did
just lose that case.
You can't just use Back from
answering a notification to
switch to the previous
task anymore.
And that is kind
of unfortunate.
But the good news is that since
we've elevated Recents
to this first-class element
that's right there on the
navigation bar all the time,
then getting back to the last
thing that you were doing
is very simple.
So the most recent task
is always sorted
closest to the button.
So it's a very quick two taps
to get back to the previous
thing that you were doing.
But more importantly, we
realized from all the user
testing that it was less
important to keep this quick
Back than it was not to surprise
people with a bogus
task state much, much
later down the road.
And to reinforce this idea of
the task switch as we go back
and forth, we really try and
tell the story with animation
in Jellybean.
RICHARD FULCHER: OK,
so wrapping up.
Three things that I'd
love you to take
away from this session.
The first is, think about the
structure of your app early on
in your planning process.
The first talk this morning
did a really good job of
illustrating how you think about
what you want your app
to achieve.
What is the app in
and of itself?
Don't be the bag
of activities.
You don't have to be like
this exact hierarchy.
There are a lot of different
hierarchies
that are out there.
And there are a lot of apps
you can look at as
exemplars of that.
You can be broad or narrow.
You could be shallow or deep.
You could be balanced or
imbalanced in your hierarchy.
Let the activities and their
relationships drive the
structure that you
try to implement.
ADAM POWELL: So another thing
that we'd like you to do is
don't just test your app
navigation in isolation.
It's very, very easy when you're
in an intense debugging
session to just make some quick
changes, push the new
APK to your device, test it out
really quick just within
your app that just launched
from your debugger,
and say, OK, great.
It works.
We're done.
The thing is is that as soon
as you have any sort of
sophisticated navigation in your
application, this doesn't
actually exercise all of the
different cases that users are
going to run into.
Make sure that you test all
of the navigation in
and out of your app.
That's the notifications,
widgets, and any sort of
intent fulfillment that
happens from other
applications.
If your application can
act as a viewer for
certain types of content.
If other applications can
share to your app.
Make sure that you test all
of those things too.
And most importantly, go ahead
and dogfood your own
application, too.
Test it over a number of days.
See how it interacts with other
applications on the system.
And make sure that it's behaving
consistently with the
other applications that
people are going to be
using day to day.
RICHARD FULCHER: And
then finally, why
are we doing this?
Why do I care about
this so much?
Users always win.
Your users are always win when
apps behave consistently.
You've heard the consistency
point a number of times today.
It's important.
There's no need for a user to
learn how to navigate your
application if you're doing
the standard, doing the
consistent thing.
They can take the knowledge
they've learned in one app and
apply it to yours directly.
You also don't have to spend
time introducing a tutorial,
teaching the users how to
use your navigation.
It gives the users a
sense of mastery.
That ability to take the
knowledge learned in one place
and apply it into a different
context is what
contributes to that.
And your app is the beneficiary
of that.
The user gets all these positive
associations with it.
Adam often talks about
this being--
kind of one way that users
express this is they say, oh
that app's intuitive.
It's just doing the things
they would expect to do
without having had to learn
what the app is
asking them to do.
And it lets the users
concentrate on the key things
your app is trying to deliver.
And then finally, it makes the
whole experience feel better
to the users.
Your app, all the apps,
all the devices.
We're working really hard to
try to bring consistency to
all of the Google
applications.
And hopefully, you'll notice
in Jellybean, we've made a
tremendous number of
improvements when it comes to
using navigation consistently.
I'm sure there's a couple
that we've missed.
We're working on it.
ADAM POWELL: We couldn't
have missed any, Rich.
I don't think that's possible.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah.
That's why they pay us
the medium buck.
We've covered a lot today.
If you want to go back and
review any of this material--
I've tried to concentrate
on the why's.
You know, why did
we come to these
decisions that we've made?
But if you just need the
guidelines, they're in the
design guide.
If you go to the navigation
pattern there,
you can review it.
It's got a lot of this content
or other related examples that
you can go through again.
And with that, thank
you very much.
[APPLAUSE]
RICHARD FULCHER: And we have
time for questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do you have some advice for
tools to draw diagrams or some
tools like UML to create the
navigation diagrams?
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah, that's
a good question.
So we use a lot of different
tools within the team.
I happen to use Illustrator just
because I do navigation
and wire framing at
the same time.
We have a number of designers
who use OmniGraffle to do
quick connections.
I've worked at places
where we've used
PowerPoint or Visio.
I'm dating myself.
Pen and paper is usually good
enough, too, oftentimes if the
app just isn't that large.
I don't know if you have
anything to add.
No.
ADAM POWELL: No, I think that,
that pretty well covers.
RICHARD FULCHER: Great.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RICHARD FULCHER: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I have a question related to
how the Back navigation is
supposed to be working
when you're having a
list view on a tablet.
So on a tablet, for example,
you have a list view.
And then you're showing it
beside it in a separate
fragment the icon, like
the item of the list.
And then on the list, you select
the next one and then
the next one and the
display shows.
What's the expected behavior?
Is there an expected behavior
of the Back button to go and
go back and show me
those other list
items that showed before?
RICHARD FULCHER: No.
The expectation is more that
Back will operate at the level
of the entire screen.
So any internal--
AUDIENCE: So then the Back
button basically behaves the
same as the app button.
RICHARD FULCHER: Again,
but it depends on how
you entered it, yes.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, but, if I enter
into the list here and
then go through the list, the
Back button doesn't actually
do the expected back operation
in terms of I went back to
that list item I saw before.
And that's expected?
RICHARD FULCHER: That's
expected.
Another example of this
would be tabs.
Back doesn't operate
across tab views.
So if I come in and I'm browsing
even on the I/O app--
I'm browsing through
the top level--
Back isn't going to take
me to the prior tab.
It's just going to treat
that all as state--
ADAM POWELL: Yeah,
that's right.
There's a few of these
constructs that we have.
And just like you mentioned,
tabs are one of them, where we
really distinguish between what
types of actions do or
don't create navigation
history.
And tabs are definitely one that
we decided do not create
navigation history.
And choosing different list
items to focus on in a
two-pane UI is another one of
those very analogous sort of
actions that doesn't itself
create navigation history.
AUDIENCE: Can you update that
in the design guide?
Because it's not explicit
from there.
And I was thinking that it
actually should be doing the
actual Back thing.
And therefore implemented
that in my app and
that's how it works.
I find that, for example, the
Gmail app and all these apps,
they don't do that.
So I'm kind of contemplating
to ripping it out again.
So you're saying that that
is the expected behavior?
Maybe update the design guide.
That would be great.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yep, I
think we can add that.
We're actually trying to add
more and more depth to our
tablet support in the
design guide.
So that's a good call-out.
Thank you.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, so I guess
we should add that same note
that we have about tabs
to the left pane list.
AUDIENCE: So with the move from
Gingerbread to Honeycomb
and ICS, you guys did away with
the option menu, which
had a visual interface and a
nice grid layout, to the
overflow menu, which is a
big giant list of text.
RICHARD FULCHER: That's right.
AUDIENCE: Now, some of us
prefer to have a visual
interface for people
rather than just a
bunch of text to read.
And so before I and others start
getting into coming up
with our own ideas of how that
menu should work, I'm curious
if you guys have had any
discussion and ideas on how to
integrate visual pieces into
the overflow menu.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah, I guess
my initial response to that
would be that the old menu would
give you visibility for
five options and then like a
More button, which would then
fall through to a text-only
display at that point.
So when we designed the Action
Bar, and particularly in ICS
when we brought it to phone,
we gave you the
split Action Bar.
So you could still have five
visible targets within your
application, if you wanted to.
And then kick over to
the text overflow.
So we tried to, in the Action
Bar, give you a similar amount
of graphical targets that
you can give it.
We don't have any plans right
now to introduce graphics into
the action overflow
itself, though.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, the idea
was really to reduce the
navigation depth that the user
had to traverse by one.
So everything that would have
appeared in that menu panel,
we're now trying to bring on
screen just by default.
So that anything that really
needs visual navigation should
be there present, that is a
little bit more discoverable
than something that's hidden
behind the Menu button.
So in that case we're
positioning the overflow menu
as something that really is
for some of those hidden
options that are not frequent,
important, or typical.
RICHARD FULCHER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So this is regarding
the Back button.
If I had to navigate a page to
an activity from a dialogue.
And I hit the Back button.
I go through the stack
of dialogues that
I didn't want to.
As a user, I would expect Back
to go to the previous
activity, without hitting all
the dialogues that I had to go
to the next activity.
So is this behavior
remaining, or--
ADAM POWELL: So which?
I'm sorry.
I guess I don't quite
understand.
So you had a case where you had
multiple nested dialogues
that were created?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, I had
two dialogues.
Which was important to make some
decisions before we go to
the next activity.
ADAM POWELL: Oh, I see.
AUDIENCE: When I hit the Back
button I would actually expect
to go to the previous activity
rather than [? fall on ?] all
the dialogues.
ADAM POWELL: Right.
So what the system alert
dialogues do by default is
whenever you choose one of those
options in the bottom
bar from the dialogue, we
actually dismiss the dialogue
as part of navigating
to the next thing.
So that way, there's no extra
states still left over.
If you're ending up with a lot
of stacked dialogues one on
top of another, then that's
probably a situation that you
want to avoid getting into
upfront, rather than worrying
about how to clean it
up after the fact.
So when you've already made a
decision from a dialogue, that
should be about it
for the dialogue.
So go ahead and dismiss it and
let the next thing take over.
RICHARD FULCHER: And the
behavior you're describing
would be kind of strange
and jarring, I agree.
We would want to not take you
back to the dialogue and take
you back to the root activity
underneath it.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, absolutely.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RICHARD FULCHER: Sure.
AUDIENCE: Hi, I'm constantly
having to explain to my
parents that there aren't
actually two Back buttons on
the screen.
RICHARD FULCHER: That's
not true.
There's two.
There's a Back and an Up.
AUDIENCE: Are there any plans to
make the Up button face up?
ADAM POWELL: So that's
kind of interesting.
We actually started--
oh.
Lots of people like this.
[APPLAUSE]
ADAM POWELL: So believe it or
not, this is actually what it
looks like in the first
release of Honeycomb.
We actually had a little
glyph that pointed
up and to the left.
And as it turned out, because
of just the way that the
spacing all works out,
nobody saw it.
It was effectively invisible.
It almost looked like a
little shaded corner.
We played around with
a lot of different
glyphs to try it out.
And in our user testing, we just
found that something a
lot more in your face that we
ended up using as that sort of
left-facing chevron was way
more effective in terms of
just how it read to the majority
of the people that we
user-tested with.
RICHARD FULCHER: Yeah,
the other thing
I'll add is like Up--
we think about Up
all the time.
Hierarchy isn't an odd concept
for most of our consumers.
They don't view apps that way.
And even though we're kind of
expressing it as the Up
button-- that's what
we call it--
they think of it as Back
in some sense.
Back in the app versus
this other Back.
AUDIENCE: Thanks, guys.
RICHARD FULCHER: Sure,
thank you.
AUDIENCE: So the Up button in
the new Google+ app opens up
that little slide app
menu on the side.
RICHARD FULCHER: Ah, we
knew this was coming.
Have you used YouTube?
AUDIENCE: I haven't checked
at YouTube.
RICHARD FULCHER: Same thing.
AUDIENCE: All right.
So is that going to
be a standard or--
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, so this is
basically the next problem
that Rich and I are going to
tackle after everything from
I/O settles down here.
This idea of the [? nab ?]
drawer is something that has
become really popular
in the community.
And we want to make sure that
we have some really strong
guidelines and support
around it.
And I think that out of some of
the different ones that are
around, I think that YouTube
probably meets most of the
direction that we're moving
toward for that.
And part of that is just because
of the way that it
implements the direct
manipulation is you can
actually grab hold of the
content and slide it over,
rather than only relying
on the Up button.
But in the case of something
like Google+, the Up button
actually is semantically
correct as well.
Because it's something where
you're saying, I want to
perform some navigation one
level up in the hierarchy from
where I currently am.
RICHARD FULCHER: As far as if
you're thinking about doing
for your apps, the things I
would keep in mind-- because I
think this will track
the guidance
we'll give most closely--
think of it as almost an
alternate visualization of the
drop-down that you can get as
a view changer as well.
It's part of the local state
of that topmost activity.
It means that where we would
never have an Up button before
on that top-most screen, we gave
you an affordance that
still looks like Up that
pulls this drawer out.
And that's in addition to any
kind of gestural affordance.
You know, an edge swipe that
you'd like to introduce that
panel with.
AUDIENCE: Sorry, are there are
plans to make this native?
ADAM POWELL: I think that
we've talked about doing
something in the support
library for it.
Of course, the problem with
adding some core navigation
pattern like this natively is
that how many people are going
to use it for the next
to 6 to 18 months.
So I think that we're probably
targeting something closer to
the support library for it.
RICHARD FULCHER: So
we don't have
anything to announce today.
But it's definitely something
we're looking at.
And just one last point I'll
throw in on that--
if that drawer is open, then
the behavior of Back should
just clearly be to cancel that
drawer and not take the
navigation.
So it's a state [? within ?]
the activity.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
go Back to [INAUDIBLE].
Why is it not [? back at the ?]
Menu icon or something?
RICHARD FULCHER: It could be
decorated differently at some
point, but for now, the
affordance we have
available is Up.
So that's what we're using.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] don't
go Up just [INAUDIBLE].
RICHARD FULCHER: I think you
don't physically move up in
terms of the options you're
presenting to the user.
They are upward.
This is a magic hierarchy.
ADAM POWELL: Right, right.
And in terms of the idea of
Back closing the drawer, I
would think of that as any of
the other sort of modal states
that you can get into.
It's the same as the IME.
It's the same as any of the
action modes that you can pull
down for editing and
so on and so forth.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
RICHARD FULCHER: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
A couple times in your
presentation, you talked about
tasks being in a bogus state--
one being you're in Gmail.
You get a notification
for a text message.
The text message shows up.
And apparently, a text message
without a corresponding
Conversation View underneath it
is somehow a bogus state.
Could you elaborate what's
bogus about that?
ADAM POWELL: Yeah.
So the idea there is that if you
have the detail view of a
particular text message, then
if you don't have the
Conversation List above it, then
the problem isn't right
there when you're
working with it.
The problem is, OK, you get
another notification.
You answer it.
You press Home.
You leave.
One thing or another.
And then you actually come back
into the SMS app or the
Talk app sometime later
through Recents.
And at that point, you've
crossed through the doorway.
And that's where you want the
Back button's behavior to be
somewhat consistent with
your expectations.
And if you start that activity
without having a Conversation
List below it, then what that
means is that the Back button
is going to finish
that activity.
And then you're going to
land back at Home.
And then that ends up being
inconsistent with expectations
that the user would have,
depending on if they got into
it from a different way, again
hours or even days earlier.
AUDIENCE: So switching back
to it from Recents
after you left it.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah.
RICHARD FULCHER: Or from
another notification.
Like any mechanism at that
point, it's going to have I
guess what I'd describe as an
incomplete state above it.
It's not invalid.
It just means that once I try to
exit it, I'm going to wind
up somewhere unexpected.
ADAM POWELL: This is one of
the things that we found
really contributed to a lot of
users feeling like Back was
unpredictable in Android
as a whole.
It wasn't a matter of what
it did right away.
It was a matter of state that
got created a really long time
ago that wasn't really
intentional.
But as soon as you come back
to it, then suddenly
everything's kind
of goofed up.
And it's right after you did
another task switch.
You're trying to do something
where your
expectations were one way.
Suddenly, you get flustered.
And it's like, oh, this
stupid phone.
I hate it.
AUDIENCE: Don't they feel
frustrated after responding to
a notification, hitting Back,
and it doesn't go back to
where they were?
RICHARD FULCHER: If they're
really familiar with that old
behavior, yes, there's some kind
of muscle learning they
have to do to shift that
behavior to Recents.
But we still think we're
supporting it.
ADAM POWELL: We've found that
in practice in our own
dogfooding with Googlers, who,
by the way, are probably the
most critical audience
for issues like this.
We had a lot of initial
frustration in
the first few days.
And then it really trailed off
after that, once you started
training yourself.
I know that I was
the same way.
Matias isn't around here, but
I actually locked him in a
conference room for the better
part of an afternoon trying to
convince him that, no, we
had to find some way
to keep this behavior.
And in the end, I was not only
convinced that this was the
right way to go.
But that once I actually started
using it this way,
once it's in action, you start
switching over to Recents.
And it becomes extremely natural
to the point where you
pick up an older device
and you're like,
this is entirely wrong.
So a lot of it really is just
a matter of habituation.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
AUDIENCE: I have a couple
of questions.
You mentioned going up through
the stack and then basically
hitting the Up and going
all the way,
bypassing the middle ones.
And you were showing the task
stack as basically having
those vanish.
But how do you make
that happen?
Since conceptually, you could
also be getting back to that
Home screen just by following
other navigation which would
put it on the top with all
those back in there.
ADAM POWELL: Yes, there's
a few ways to do this.
The first is that, well, in
Jellybean and forward, there's
actually a specific method
that does this.
Or, wait, no, that's--
never mind.
That's a different case.
So as you're jumping up for
that type of navigation,
essentially you have this other
flag that's called Flag
Activity Clear Top.
And it means that I'm launching
into this task, but
clear everything else off the
top if this same target
activity already exists
in my task stack.
So we've used this in the past
to really try and prevent
cycles in navigation.
And that's exactly what it does
in this case, as well.
AUDIENCE: OK, and somewhat
similar.
We respond to a number of
deep links we capture.
You've probably formatted
URLs, etc.
And so if we come in for item A,
and then we stay in the app
for a little bit, and
then we go back out.
And we come in again following
another link for item B. And
we go off a ways.
So our stack for our
task currently has
items A and B on it.
And so those are handled by
the same activity, just
different data.
Now we get a deep link again for
item A, but it just brings
our activity to the front
showing item B.
ADAM POWELL: Yes.
That's that task switching
behavior that we described
when it matches the
root intent.
So I'm guessing that your data
URI is an exact match for what
A was in that particular case.
So that's definitely why you're
seeing that behavior.
AUDIENCE: Actually, it's not.
ADAM POWELL: It's not?
AUDIENCE: Or sorry, it's an
exact match for item A, yes.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, yeah.
So if it's an exact match for
item A, that's why it's
bringing that task forward, even
though you've got other
tasks still on top of it.
So generally, it sounds like
this means that your activity
is acting as a viewer, sort of
as a helper for another app.
Is that correct?
AUDIENCE: Actually-- well,
I'm with IMDb.
So basically, if somebody
follows a link that has been
shared to them, or whatever,
or a title or a
celebrity or whatever.
ADAM POWELL: So it's basically
a web link that you've
registered an HTTP URI
Intent Filter for?
AUDIENCE: Right.
ADAM POWELL: Excellent.
So generally, the way that we
do this is that that doesn't
actually launch a new task.
So that shouldn't be launching
a new task to begin with.
Because it's conceptually part
of exactly what the user was
doing in whatever task
linked them to it.
So that's our case before, where
we were doing the share
YouTube video off to Gmail.
Where in that case, the detail
view from the IMDb app would
be launching as an activity on
the current task already.
So in that case, you wouldn't
be creating this other state
that you've still
got left here.
Now, there's another flag which
is kind of important to
be aware of for this
that is useful when
linking out to this.
But sometimes when you're just
handling an HTTP URI, it's not
really feasible to be
able to set it.
But that's Flag Activity
Clear When Task Reset.
So it's kind of a mouthful.
But what that does is that makes
a distinction on whether
or not the user comes back.
So say they were
in the browser.
So they're in the browser.
They hit a link to an
IMDb page, and it
brings up the app instead.
So it's launched that on the
browser's activities stack.
Now ideally, if you're linking
them from something else and
using this as sort of
a viewer, you could
also set this flag.
And then that means that if
the user later comes in
through Recents, then,
OK, it's exactly
the same as it was.
The IMDb activity
is still on top.
But in the case where the user
relaunches from the Launcher
itself, they press Browser.
They want to get browser.
They don't want to
get the IMDb app.
So that actually acts as that
task reset at that point.
And any cut points where that
flag was specified, all those
tasks get finished and
are cleared off.
But that aside, the general idea
is that you really want
to be trying to launch within
the current task of whatever
is linking into your activity.
So that that way you don't end
up creating your own task
stack of a whole ton of
extra history there.
AUDIENCE: OK.
On certain links, then,
we used the clear top.
But I'm not sure that the
activity that actually
responds to that intent actually
gets dismissed and
this other fragment activity
gets loaded on top.
ADAM POWELL: Oh, I see.
So this is when you're
navigating Up from that other
detail view from before, or--
AUDIENCE: No, it's actually in
order to cover some of the
other cases, we had to have
basically an activity chooser
activity that handles the
intent coming in.
And then goes off to fragment
activities that actually load
everything else.
So it's a little complicated.
ADAM POWELL: I see.
So you've essentially got a
detail activity that holds a
bunch of other pieces then?
RICHARD FULCHER: We're
over our time.
So let's just cut the questions
on the mic off.
Please feel free to come up.
And then everybody
else can go.
ADAM POWELL: Yeah, definitely.
If we get kicked out of this
room, then let's talk more
outside, too.
RICHARD FULCHER: Thanks.